c'est une situation sans précédent en
même temps la guerre à grande échelle en
Ukraine est aussi une situation sans
précédent et effectivement il Prigogine
qui est à la tête d'un empire de
propagande aussi on le rappelle en
Russie à beau dire que c'est une marche
pour la justice moi cela fait quelques
semaines que je dis que c'est l'opposant
numéro 1 en Russie à Vladimir Poutine
donc il emploie des mots d'un opposant
et d'un combattant pour la liberté mais
évidemment il n'appelle pas un chat un
chat en tant que propagandiste en chef
et ceux qui le déclare vouloir faire là
ce serait un coup d'État militaire
puisqu'il ne dit pas autre chose que ce
que vous avez mentionné c'est-à-dire
qu'il va prendre son armée de 25000
forces qu'il a entraîné ou bien
prisonnier ou bien ce qu'il en reste et
il appelle tous les autres toute l'autre
force qu'on battante russe active et
potentielle à le rejoindre pour marcher
de fait sur Moscou pour prendre de force
les institutions pour renverser voire
éliminer Serge le ministre de la Défense
et Valérie guerassimov le chef d'Ét
at-major des armées qu'il a qualifié de
traître responsable 1 2 d'avoir menti
sur les causes de la guerre en Ukraine
et de d'avoir d'être responsable de la
mort de dizaines de milliers de Russes